[Music]
well everybody and welcome to the
endgame class it took me just a minute
to get everything started there
apologies for those in the chat room but
we are up and running here and today
like I said at the end of the previous
class I want to walk you through some
really interesting end games from the
legends of chess tournament going on
right now on chess 24 some really big
names in this events and on your screen
I do have a picture of Peters fiddler
because we're gonna be going over an end
game of his against offici
Anand first off here right off the bat
it was a really interesting ruck end
game and we're not gonna take a look at
the beginning of the game or the middle
of the game because that is not the name
of this class so we are going to look at
the end game which did arrive after the
move rook c4 Queen takes d5 lean takes
d5 rook takes d5 Bishop takes g4 f g4
rook g4 and now we are solidly in the
endgame here so I like to sort of pause
at the beginning of each of these end
games and ask the chat to kind of give
me their thoughts so here I want to ask
the chatroom
what do we think is going on in this
particular position first of all you
know what kind of tactics are we going
to see and then maybe we'll pause again
after after some of the tactics have
have calmed down and we sort of have you
know a position that we can just think
about what do we think
so yeah of course rook d7 check is
definitely on the cards and so in the
game first of all it's fiddler did
defend this g3 pawn can play rook d7
first if you really want but so they're
just plays Rick f2 defending g3 the
strut came over to c4 no wait for this
rook to defend b7 and if you play a move
like b6 or anything well you're still
gonna run into this check and this pawn
is still going to end up falling so just
king F 2 to 10 G 3 and then we saw
Trixie for this check King h6 and takes
on b7 visi now plays the move rook c1
and so this is the point where I really
want to pause so obviously here white is
a pawn to good but we still need to sort
of figure out how we're going to go
about trying to win this endgame
position so I want you guys to kind of
stop for a moment think here see if you
can find some sort of winning plan
winning idea for Peter Svidler here
Rohan is asking what's the point of rook
to c1 well the point is white was
actually making a threat if black just
sort of passes Rick before is gonna come
on the board anyways and this work is
gonna have to move you know it can't
really take here because the Kingdom
pawn endgame is going to be losing down
the pawn for black so this you chose
sorry I'm backing up too far fishy shows
Rick c1 to be able to play rook be one
next to sort of attack this pawn from
behind so that's all wants to play b4 to
sacrifice the pawn and get the rook
active with the past pawn
mati wants to play rook before rook b1
and then bring the King over to c2 any
other ideas move the King to the Queen
side as being suggested again so what's
the problem
right there's actually a small problem
right I do like starting with drift
before we'll go ahead and put this on
the board
this is the best square for the rook it
attacks the week a pawn it defends the
week be pawn and it guards the entire
Kings side as well for many sort of
forays that the black King might be
thinking about doing however if we take
a look here Rick b1 if we sort of just
naively try to bring our King over to
the Queen side here we're gonna run into
some slight issues right let's say the
move f5 comes on the board can you see -
and now Ricky one ok and so all of a
sudden if we get a little bit greedy try
to take on a four rook takes e - and
rookie three we get to run our pawns but
hold on it's it's really not so clear
anymore what's going on right you know
our palms only run so fast and blacks
pawns are now quite past as well and any
potted Vantage that we did have is going
to end up not being here anymore
if we allow the black rook to sort of
get active in this manner in fact I do
think this endgame is just going to be a
draw so just sort of naively bringing
the King over to the Queen side like
this isn't actually going to get the job
done for us so we need to find some kind
of good idea here oh yeah hello from
hello to the viewers in Poland at least
there's one of them glad you could you
could stay up late to check out the show
and so yeah the guys in the chat are
actually a little bit ahead of me here
the best move is in fact I think
the move that Peter played which is the
move g4 and this is actually a pretty
counterintuitive move that you wouldn't
expect to be good in this type of
endgame the point is simply that this
rook on b4 from the fourth file would
love to take on a fork and also defend
the weaknesses on the Kings side however
this work is obviously not able to
defend the Jeep on so by playing g4 we
kind of removed this weakness on g3
bring it to a square where the rook can
guard it and at the same time we're
preventing the black King from advancing
all at the same time now why do I say
this is counterintuitive well generally
in these types of end games the
attacking side wants to keep as many
pawns on the board as possible
that's because if the defending side can
get rid of all the pawns obviously the
game is gonna be a draw the tête the
defending side also quite often aims for
rook and pawn in games where there's
just one pawn left on the board and they
can achieve some type of drawn position
by getting their king in front of it
right it's quite often going to be a
draw when when that scenario sort of
arises so it does really make sense to
keep as many pawns on the board as
possible for white however g4 does allow
the move f5 which black can and did play
cam should indeed play which does trade
off pawns so we see G takes f 5 and G
takes f 5 however I do still think that
this idea was a good one by Peter
Svidler because now he sort of moved his
weakness from g3 to h4 a square where
the rook can more easily guard it and on
top of that he's given black and new
weakness as well now the f5 pawn is also
going to be weak and if black doesn't go
for this idea of f5 just sort of passes
with King g7 well now this King is going
to be very very inactive here on the g7
square and in fact white can go about
trying to win the game by advancing the
King up the board rather than sort of
staying back here in card and mr. rook
lines where the King does come this way
are also going to be more advantageous
in this case than the case we just
looked at because of course these pawns
aren't mobilizing
as quickly all of this is to say g4 is a
great move by Pierce food they're here
to help restrict the black king and slow
down these black pawns
we did see f5g takes up 5g takes f5y
York before well I've just been talking
up this written before this whole time
on before the rook defends our weakness
defends the weakness over here and is
also threatening to take a four and the
type of endgame white is really looking
for here is a two V zero on the Queen
side if you can kind of achieve this and
black only ends up with one passed pawn
on the Kings side then white is always
going to be winning right connected
passed pawns unopposed are going to be
far far too much for black to handle and
so this work on before is always
threatening to do that if this rook ever
gets any ideas of sort of leaving the
defense the attack of this pot right
rook takes a four is an immediate win
now for white so the point is we have a
rook on a square where it does active
things on the Kings side and it's
totally neutralizing the black Kirk as
well for us you need to stay on b1
what if black plays Rick h1 well once
again that's part of the beauty of this
idea of the rook on b4 white is always
going to be happy to trade this pawn for
the Aged pawn here the reason being
first of all h g5 check wins the game
immediately
but even if g5 check weren't in the
position here we could also just sort of
play a move like King g3 rook h1 and
start advancing these pawns and black is
not going to have a passed pawn on the
Kings side anytime soon and we can sort
of start trying to advance these
connected passers slowly but surely okay
but yeah also important g5 check would
win the game here as these pawns are a
little bit too fast over here and the
King is well in time to stop these pawns
well the black king is nowhere close
enough to catching this pawn so g4 great
move by Sadler we have takes and takes
and now King III
I stood there as well ready to sort of
advance and now king h5 was played in
the game and so once again I want to
pause and ask you guys at home what do
you think White's should play here to
try to win the game
what should white go for I'd say there
are actually three kind of main
competing plans that you can choose
nothing no name let's to play king d -
so he's choosing one of the three plans
with the king D - right so I'll just
highlight his plan he wants to come to
see to force the rook off of b1 and
capture a four that's definitely one
plan Manny says the move King at four
and this is definitely planned number
two King F [ __ ] the idea is you do give
up this pawn on h4 but you get this pawn
on f5 for it instead okay so we have two
votes for king d2 and two votes for King
at four no votes for plan number three
because I will tell you in the game it's
fiddler played neither of these moves
would that be king d4 not quite Switzer
simply captured on a for giving up this
pawn on b2 this was Fiddler's idea to
win the game and I think this may still
be a technically winning position but
it's much much much more difficult and
then it was in previous positions and I
think with good play black might
actually be closer to drawing this that
he is to to losing it so I like your
guys's ideas better than Peter spoilers
how about that and now we are seeing
some people say takes a four so let's
start with the plan of King to f4 what's
the idea here well the idea is simply
king Tate's age for King takes that five
with a check and now this King has to go
somewhere let's say King g3 and all of a
sudden the movie for is sort of coming
quite quickly right the movie fort is
sort of coming quickly the downside to
this of course is that you are giving
black a very very strong passed pawn on
age five and in fact if you play the
movie for sort of nonchalantly I think
II five may even be enough to draw you
five Rick f1 check this King has to
leave and Ricky one let's say Ritchie
5h4
and it's tough to both advance this pawn
and keep an eye on the black pawn as
well that being said I do think white is
actually still winning here with the
mover of g4 check followed by e for now
in this way it's much much easier to
advance this pawn with this i clicked
something let me refresh ok much much
easier to advance this pawn with this
work here to block checks and this king
sort of hampering his own pawns
advancement in this manner
so King f4 I think is in fact a winning
plan with the caveat that you have to
find this really key move rook g4 check
the idea being now either this pawn is
too lonely with the king way over here
or
the king sort of stands in its own way
after the move age five Rick f4 and now
taking pawns on the Kings side the Queen
side rather is going to be a little bit
too slow with moves like e5 coming quite
quickly even Ricci for here let's say we
have a check kingi five can't really
advance this guy and this pawn is going
to just simply win the game okay so King
takes up or King out for great idea
anybody who said King at four I do think
that this one is enough to win the game
now King d2 is this enough to win the
game well let's take a look let's say
the move h6 gets played King see - Ricky
1 or takes a four is the idea or it
takes a to check King c3 have to keep an
eye on this guy and now let's say just
for example for d3 check and Rick after
right so what do you guys think of this
end game compared to the last one what
do you guys think of this one compared
to the one that we just looked at and in
fact let me have changed the position
slightly I think I like to have two
better then this idea of Arc f3
beltron says passive king for which side
Aqib says draw Killian thinks it's
winning mani is suggesting Rick a five
fortunately Rick a five I do think hangs
this opponent h4 drew might not quite be
ready for so this one I think is
definitely much closer than the king f4
line and the reason I think that is
because in the king of horror line we
sort of end up with these three pawns on
the Queen side and so if things sort of
liquidate on the Kings side white still
has chances to win but by getting rid of
the a4 pawn black sort of always has to
be guarding this a4 upon as well
otherwise white is is going to be taking
it or at least black has to be on the
lookout for ideas of taking the night
for because there are many positions
where I could just capture there and
then go on to win the game whereas in
this case with the a4 pawn already gone
there are some things that are very very
different here first and foremost our
King is on c3 rather than being on an
active square like f4 or f5 as we saw in
the previous case also you know white
may already have these Queen side pawns
but in exchange for them black is first
and foremost already having his own past
pawn on f5 and he's also going to be
able to sort of make a second pass pawn
if King takes h4 Advocates played and so
is white winning here it's sort of
unclear I suspect he may be with the
move like b4 and in just an example line
here Rick f3 king D 2
and then let's say the move rack at four
okay five paint a stage for B 554 check
teenie 256 ok 6 for example and things
gets a get rather complex right things
get rather complex view you have a
definite pond race now and I do think
white is is gonna end up winning it but
I will say I do like this plan a lot lot
less than the king king to f4 plan and
so that leaves the the third plan the
plan that's Fiddler's shows so once
again I like this plan the best because
we get a very active King we only have
to worry about this age pond and our
king is in very close vicinity to this
age pond to help sort of stop it but
once again you do need to spot this idea
of rip g4 check before II for with the
point being we get our rook on a very
active square before before before
pushing the C pawn now R it takes b2 is
far too slow because II five is picking
up the a4 pawn as well like I said white
maintaining these threats on the Queen
side and then there's the idea that's
what they're chose of rook takes a four
and for the same reason that I didn't
like the idea of King D two kings C two
is the same reason why I don't like this
idea of rook takes a four
it's better to sort of keep these
threats on the Queen side sort of in
your pocket as White's making sure you
can always take on a for later if you
need it rather than take on a for
immediately and sort of relieve the
tension on b2 now after rook takes b2
stood there plays rook b4 and then sorry
the study got a bit messed up but I
fixed it
we have rook B 4 brick a to getting
behind the passed pawn a for now and now
this she simply plays the move h6
getting this pawn to a square where the
King can easily defend it
and now actually white goes ahead and
plays the move King up for anyways and I
guess the point I'm trying to make is if
you were having to play the move King
effort anyways I'd rather have these
pawns still sitting on a 4 and B 2
rather than not sitting there because
now rather than blacks are being tied
down it's actually White's rook that is
gonna be the the more tied down piece in
this case that being said I think so
there may actually still have a winning
position so the question to you is
should black be capturing on the e2 pawn
or not is this upon that that black
should capture what do you guys think
rohan says he thinks it's lost either
way
what's the issue with rip takes you to
if it is so poisoned
what is the problem
qg6 looks stronger man he says King d6
Jack says take um so okay by suggesting
qg6
I guess you guys see the problem the
problem is that white is simply going to
capture on f5 and this end game is very
strictly winning because this King is
just so so awful here on a on h5 just
for example right back to a2 might be a
good idea now this King is gonna step
out in this direction the King tries to
step out here we can just run the King
all the way over to the Queen side and
our rook is still going to be in a very
good position to guard this weakness as
well just for example this pawn running
up the board so black definitely can't
take on e - now what black can try is
king g6 as fish you tried in the game or
the slightly counterintuitive move rook
c2 so what's the idea of rook c2 who
sees the idea here it's it's a good one
it's a good one
what's blacks idea with York c2
chess King says your xe5 rib goes to a
eight yes
stalemate tricks as Voltron's set so
Trixie 2 is actually a very very
inventive way to play King takes f5
because now not Rick c5 check but Brooke
c4 is surprisingly very very strong here
for black the white rook has to leave
and now rook takes a 4 and the game is
going to be a draw it's just a table to
table base draw at this point believe it
or not something like e 4 Rick an 8 rook
e1 Rick a faint check king e5 and now
King takes h4 and this game is a draw
black is eventually gonna sacrifice the
rook for the pod and promote his own
pond over here
when white will also have to sacrifice
so believe it or not I think rook c2 may
be a game saving move here for for black
now white can actually still try you
just can't take on f5 the move is gonna
have to be e for here and now the only
move for black distil try is rook F to
check can't take on e4 or else you run
into the same issues can't take on h4
because unfortunately King d3 will win
the game
so we're gave to King III now look back
to a2 and white can play the move e5 but
it's a little bit more complex with
these two pawns still on the board
and now ideas like King g6 are gonna
come on the board once again and it's a
little bit unclear to me if white is
actually winning this position this one
is still going to be quite a fight
things like oh it could be six check but
just King g7 and I'm honestly not sure
on this endgame it feels like white
might still be winning but definitely a
lot of tricks to look out for here as
well now in the game understandably it's
a rapid game wish you didn't see this
idea which is pretty non-standard
but could have been a fun one to try to
save the game now white plays the movie
three just removing it from the threat
of capture Rick a3 was vicious choice
and now after epi six check we have King
h5 Rick a6 by swindler and this is a
good repositioning of the rook the idea
now is that King takes aged four would
be a bit of a mistake due to checkmate
and the rook is just gonna be more
actively placed to help this pawn
advance forward in the game we saw
Brooke b3 sort of giving up on stopping
the a plug and going for activity over
here excuse me but then a rook d6
Spicewood there was not a bad idea
either however I do think the move a5
was going to be a bit simpler here not
just pushing this pawn up the board and
then if black really wants to continue
these ideas of keeping the ruck active
then he's gonna run into some pretty
serious serious issues with this pawn
sort of just running up the board really
anything would win here but a6 for
example and this guy is ready ready to
rock and ready to roll in the game
though rook d6 and I do think this is
still fine rook a3 though and now
honestly the idea for fiddler has to be
to keep this a pawn on the board without
the a pawn the end games do end up being
a lot more drawn than they are than they
are winning in the game Swigert goes
King takes f5 and unfortunately after it
takes a 4 and the game is going to be
going to be a draw so definitely what's
what they needed to do here is either
push the pawn or after rip d6 rotate
three you could go back to this idea of
having the Rex sit on d4 but I do like
this sort of winning attempt less than
having the reckon a6 for example if King
g6 here you can play the movie 4 and go
back to this winning endgame which once
again is very easy to win
with this idea of bringing the king to
the Queen side but with the rook on a
six maybe it's even simpler with just
pushing this pawn up the board step by
step by step however though you know I
really do like this idea of playing e4
here you just have to be a little bit on
the lookout for stuff like Kirk a1 but
this would of course give this free pawn
or what it retakes a4 is a nice idea
things are so complicated this is why I
should stick to the stuff that I
actually have prepped which is rook a
six being a winning move right the idea
being you push the pawn to a5 after
anything like okay three now you can
actually go ahead and take here this
idea doesn't work because birth takes is
not stalemate
so King f5 and then these end games are
sort of always going to be winning now
for for white you push this guy up the
board this is way too slow because it
takes and rip back a six and this pawn
is still not capturable
thanks to rip takes h6 and white is
going to bring the King over to the
Queen side once again so a bit of a
heart breaker here for Peter Svidler
the game itself did end in a draw so
there pushes this pawn but now
unfortunately the black king is in good
enough position to draw this game
like I said black or the defending site
often aims for these types of positions
where there's only one pawn left on the
board because many of them do turn out
to be a draw so Recces one wreck f2 and
now the drawing idea takes advantage of
the fact that this king guards all of
the squares on the short side of the
pond now is this the short side defense
no that's something different there's so
many different names for these things in
Rickon games but the idea here for black
is that this king guards all the squares
where white could shelter itself behind
the pawn and so now of course checking
from the side is sort of an unstoppable
draw right this King has nowhere on the
board to hide besides the square like g2
which now obviously
this is going to be a drop so the King
ran up the board but there's nowhere to
hide and then the king tried running
towards the rook but rookie six came out
five and this pawn is a dead one and so
the game was eventually drawn now this
was a really interesting wreck end game
to start with unfortunately it didn't go
Peters for the lose way but it's really
interesting to see those three different
plans that we sort of had at that
crossroads and choosing between them
I think Peter definitely chose wrong
with rook takes a four I think King F
four was a little bit of a simpler win
and the reason for that I think is is
really instructive going back to it one
more time the idea here is that King F 4
is the easiest way to try to win this
game because after rook g4 check King
h3e for white gets this nice past epon
and still is threatening to get a passed
pawn on the Queen side with two passed
pawns white should be able to win and
you are also eliminating blacks best
threat of this pawn on f5 sort of from
the get-go so rather than take a four
and try to deal with f5 later I think it
makes a lot more sense to take at five
and deal with a for later because a four
is much more difficult for black to try
to defend okay let's go ahead and move
on to the next game that I want to look
at and this is one between Ivanchuk
and Peter Lecco and I don't want to
spend too too long on this end game
because the ideas is pretty simple but
it's definitely one worth knowing so
let's jump straight to the endgame we
don't care about this opening stuff or
this middle game stuff I hate it it's
not the middle game class this is not
the opening class this is the endgame
class so here we are finding ourselves
in an endgame
so what do we think is going on here is
either side better why is either side
better isn't equal what are the plans
what is going on yet none of this middle
game rubbish that's not for this class
that's for a different class so what do
we have here
I keep prefers black white is better
because of the night on f5 being really
good chess King likes black so in end
games where there are Queens on the
board especially a huge thing to look at
is safety of the Kings in this case I do
think that both sides do have relatively
safe Kings so that's first thing that I
always look at here and I do think that
both sides have relatively safe King's
you could argue that blacks King is a
little bit safer due to this extra C
pawn and the C pawn not being here for
white but there's really no way to take
advantage of it right the only way would
be some type of check on this diagonal
and after Knight f5 you're really not
getting that kind of check right did we
just love his face yeah you were keeping
Svidler on you know I didn't I didn't
get I didn't get a picture of Peter
Lecco in time sorry so you're stuck
you're stuck with fiddler from the rest
of the class so the safety of the Kings
is is pretty e even here I would say the
next thing to look at is who can make
better use of their knight and that's
what you guys are kind of looking at
immediately and so whose Knight is gonna
be better here well White's threatening
to jump into f5 but actually black is is
gonna have a really decent square on d4
as well and we do see in the game that
black plays 94 in the next turn perhaps
with the idea of sort of preventing the
move
95 the third thing I would want to look
at and maybe essentially well one of the
first things you should look at is you
know what's going on with the pawns as
well does that either side have a passed
pawn first and foremost
generally if any site does have a passed
pawn that's the side you should be
preferring and here of course you know
neither side has a passed pawn neither
really has the potential to create a
passed pawn in the immediate future and
because of all these reasons I do think
it's safe to say that this endgame is is
pretty equal now objectively the endgame
being equal is great but that still me
that doesn't mean that you can't really
prefer a side here and I think the side
to be preferred as you might expect from
the results is going to be black
what's the reason for that well I think
black just has a few more options to
sort of shake things up right black can
sort of threaten to try and invade
through a move like Queen g5 at a later
date I can try and invade on the dark
squares over here and then that's really
where you do feel the absence of a c3
pawn and black is always going to have
threats of moving this pawn up to h4
sort of at the right moment whereas for
white really the only conceivable way to
shake things up is with c 3 and d 4 and
as we might see in the game these moves
do come with certain risks so with 94
you might think this move is sort of
baiting the move c 3 and in fact perhaps
it was queen f 2 was played in the game
and after queen east 7 we do in fact see
the move c 3 keeping the black queen out
of b4 and kicking this night from d4 so
96 played in the game and now Knight f5
and you might start to think that the
tide is sort of turning in White's favor
but I would definitely disagree I think
this is a case of white kind of trying
to over push here
after the move Queen d7 just removing
the Queen from the threat of capture you
see d4 right now
he takes d4 C takes d4 comes on the
board now we have the move Knight g7
which makes sense white was using his
knight utilizing his Knight to better
effect than black and now we see the
move g4 by white and I want to get your
guys's opinion on the move g4 good idea
bad idea what's going on here would want
to play him I wouldn't want to play
Peters food there either wouldn't want
to play I'm terrible bad awful
why why why why is it bad
tell me I want to know tell me why
everybody thinks it's a bad move so most
of you guys have the right idea the
issue with this move is that black is
very seriously going to try to make this
h-bomb past and in a queen endgame
having a passed pawn is sort of the the
end-all peel and would you believe me if
I told you that this game ends in five
more moves with a black victory after
this move chief or it turns out this
move is simply just giving black a very
very serious advantage Knight takes that
v was played in the game and now white
absolutely must take back with the e
pawn if he wants to stay in this game
the idea being this pawn is not gonna be
passed just yet and we have some time to
remove this guy before he gets out of
control for example between e8 you would
love to play a move like Queen h4 but
hold on with C 3 and T 4
White has actually given up a second
advantage and that is the advantage in
King's safety now Queen e2 check is
going to be quite strong with the idea
of picking up some of these pawns on the
Queen side as well just for example here
stuff could get a little bit a little
bit crazy a little bit out of hand for
white with his lack of King safety and
so that's why definitely after the move
C 3 and d 4 it might be tempting to say
that you think that's white is better
but I would actually rather play the
black side the reason for that once
again being after moved like 97 even if
white doesn't blunder and plays Knight
takes g7 Queen takes g7 it's going to be
black with the safer King between these
two and while white is the one
threatening and fighting to create past
pawns here I would almost always rather
pick the side with the safer King
okay and after she takes that five now
all of a sudden black is the one with
the safer King and with the past pawn in
the game Peter like oh did immediately
play the move h4 with the idea being if
white captures on age four black is
gonna take on d4 and then we'll see
similar end games to what we just looked
at with the black queen and getting
active I'm not sure if this was honestly
the best way to go for black you could
argue that black should try to keep this
pawn on the board at all costs and try
to use it to win the game but obviously
this is going to be coming with some
amount of risk right for example Queen
h2 and stuff like a five coming on the
board
is this good immediately I'm not so sure
but you would end up with with similar
stuff I think to age four immediately so
h4 played immediately in the game and
then sort of now the fatal mistake for
Ivan trick is he didn't take this pawn
off the board when he had the chance
this move is sort of required at this
point you have to get rid of this aged
pawn
well great Wolf's better pawn structure
is sort of a sort of misleading here
black's pawn structure is fantastic for
King's safety and that's kind of the
most important thing in these end games
is your King safety well as well as of
course passed pawns and so while White's
pawn structures may be classically
better black's pawn structure is great
for protecting his King and so after
Queen takes h4 Queen takes d4 check
would have come and so you know this is
sort of an interesting position here
maybe the move c5 would come on the
board and honestly this one is is
probably still drawn for white you know
he just hasn't done enough wrong and
that being said we are definitely at a
point where black is to be preferred
here thanks to the you know lasting
advantage in King's safety in the game
though we see the move d5 and now the
move Queen h7 is great by Peter Blekko
to keep a hold of this age pawn
D takes c6 King takes c6 and now after
the move Kings c3 simply h3 Queen age to
Queen age five and Ivanchuk resigns very
very quickly things go wrong for white
in this endgame and now the reason I
even check resigns is because even
though you know material is even white
has some ideas of creating past poems
over here passed pawns and Queen on
games are sort of just absolutely
monsters if you get a passed pawn in a
queen endgame you know this position
really it wouldn't matter if white had
pawns here in here as well if white had
like four pots over here on this side of
the board it doesn't really matter the
age pawn is the only pawn that's gonna
make a difference here in this game and
because of that black is just totally
totally winning in this position the
black queen gets to g2 and this pawn is
able to promote White has no chances of
perpetual checks because of blacks
stunning Kings safety over here thanks
to his Queen side pawns so the point of
this game is that even these deceptively
drawn positions can go wrong quite
quickly if you're not going to be
careful lesson number two don't
underestimate the passed pawn in a queen
endgame many games have been lost like
this alright moving on we do have a
third game here between Vladimir Kramnik
and Jana poem initiate let's jump into
it in the middle game we did see that
Kramnik extra manages to win in East 7th
pawn through some tactics and he's gonna
hold on to this extra pawn going into
this endgame here we saw h5 and now a
clever move by white to get rid of this
active rook rook on f1 isn't doing much
so we would love to trade a pair rucks
rook a1 after rook D - D - Lucy takes
and takes and now rook c1 by white and
we are very firmly in this endgame
yawn makes a very good move to start
with here why is the past pawn such a
big deal in the Queen end games it's
because of the versatility of the Queen
jumping back really quickly so the Queen
is able to sort of maneuver around the
pawn and guard it at the same time and
what this allows the side with the past
plant to do is while defending the pawn
you can actually bring your Queen to
sort of the square in front of the pawn
in the previous endgame
jeetu you can bring the Queen to g2
quite easily and from G to the attacking
Queen manages to get rid of the
defending Queen the defending Queen has
to leave and so the Queen can help
advance the pond and defend the pawn at
the same time you can compare this to a
rook endgame where you have a wreck
behind the pawn rook in front of the
pawn neither side is gonna be able to
make any progress without the help of
other pieces Queens on their own are
able to advance the past pawns
without any other pieces and especially
when it's just a king and queen on the
board the King isn't gonna be much help
because the King often can't even get
close because the Queens are such
powerful pieces in their own right okay
back to this yawn plays a very good move
next to help his drawing chances here he
is just down a full pawn as we've said
in the past it's very important for the
defending side to try to get rid of
pawns and so he comes up with the move
a5 to get rid of the last pawns on the
Queen side
now if the move be fiber played you
could expect Yan to trade on c5 and play
the move rook e1 when there's no
comfortable way to defend this pawn
without allowing the a pawn to become
very very active play might continue b6
takes takes and then we get these poems
off the boards anyways if you try
something like Bishop c6
you're sort of asking for trouble Weiss
gonna start activating the King and you
really have no way to advance this pawn
and stuff like a 4 is almost really
gonna force your hand to play b6 and go
back into this endgame anyways okay so
long story short a 5 is a good move to
get these pawns off the board
now we have B takes a five and rook
takes a five and Bishop d6 rip b5 Bishop
e3 and Bishop back to geez okay all the
pieces are protected now on protected
squares and we are squarely in this
endgame so just a little bit of
background on end games like these I
will confess to you that I have not
studied to bishops and rook against two
bishops and rook four versus three on
the Kings side in particular but I do
know some things about end games like
these so let me tell you about them if
both pairs of Bishops are off the board
the game is almost always just quite
easily drawn by the side with three
pawns sometimes white does win those
games but theoretically that endgame
should be a draw you know practically
over the board it can have some
difficulties but rook versus rook four
versus three
supposed to be a draw if you play it
well so that's thing number one so what
does that mean that means that white
likely is going to be trying to keep the
bishops on the board because with
bishops on the board you know it's it's
a little bit unclear if it's even
theoretically drawn right so kramnik is
gonna aim to keep at least one set of
bishops on the board maybe even both
sets of bishops and that's really the
most important thing about this endgame
thing number two I guess is that black
is obviously still quite happy to
welcome any pawn trades as they get him
closer to a draw but that being said
black isn't really able to sort of you
know seek out these trades by advancing
these pawns because then those pawns are
just gonna end up weak and he's gonna
end up weakening his own King as well
thing number three as I sort of just
hinted at oftentimes the best defense in
these end games is sort of for black to
just sit back and do nothing right kind
of let white take his best shot at him
put his pieces on squares where they're
gonna be solid defend a lot of squares
try and restrain
to the white king and the white pieces
as much as possible but not do much
beyond that
black is quite often quite content to
sort of sit and pass the time while
white takes his best shot at winning
this endgame alright so we know all
these things so with the white pieces we
would like to keep bishops on the board
we would like to keep pawns on the board
as well absolutely and we know that our
opponent isn't really going to be trying
to do too much in the way of active play
so with all of that in mind let's try
and come up with some winning ideas here
what kind of tools do we have in our
toolbox to try to win this endgame no
pun intended I honestly don't know what
pun I said I deeply apologize I stand
firmly against puns in my classes create
a pasty pawn so yep easier said than
done but definitely advancing the pawns
is going to be part of White's plan here
and the key I think to winning this type
of endgame with bishops on the board the
reason it's more tricky than just the
pure rook endgame is because you can
start going after the King right with
this many pieces on the board oftentimes
you can start going after the King and I
think that's the key to try to win to
win this type of endgame other than that
advancing the pawns is great creating a
pasty pawn is much easier said than done
and if why can't create a pasty pawn
quite often wins if you can't then then
black sometimes is able to hold the draw
so let's just jump into it and see how
Kramnik treated the position he starts
with a simple move rook d1 this move
doesn't really do anything on its own
but it is sort of eyeing the d8 square
black simply plays Bishop out to f6 like
I said trying to restrict the white
pieces but not doing too much actively
and then we saw h3 by Kramnik King g7
roof d6 Bishop e5 now Rick a6
rook be to rock a5 and I'm
fast-forwarding a bit
because not too much is happening here
we just see some maneuvering and then
Kramnik does go for this move
g-force so what do you guys think is G
for allowing hg hg progress for white or
closer to a draw now for black than it
was before what do you think progress
for white or a bad decision black is
closer to a draw so testing says trading
pawns bad and so yeah Aaron is Aaron and
PLO are hitting upon the upside to
playing g4 so of course if possible
white wanted to keep pawns on the board
but Kramnik is sort of prioritizing the
fact that he's trying to get at the
black king with this move chief force so
he's willing to give up these H pawns in
exchange for the fact that now he's
gonna be able to play this move chief v
and with g5 the black king is going to
be coming under just a little bit more
pressure so I actually like this idea by
Kramnik practically to apply some
pressure here Rick before was played in
the game now g5 and this Bishop comes
out to d4 and I think this is sort of
the the issue here for kramnik is he's
not able to keep the dark squared bishop
on the board to go along with this new
attacking position that the Jeep on has
found itself in so I do think that
something and sort of gone wrong here
for Kramnik and that's why I think the
move Bishop c3 is actually a great idea
here for for black
for example if black had played a little
bit more nonchalantly something like
Bishop f6 g4 comes on the board Rick
before g5 now all of a sudden these
bishops stay on the board you can easily
imagine now that if this bishop ever
lands here this rook lands over here
uh-oh that's going to be
check me for example okay one already is
starting to create some some threats and
so I think
Kramnik unfortunately after the bishop
trade is going to be struggling a bit
sorry I'm losing my place so we have
fish 54 take some tea for it take some
d4 and now after III rook c4 I think
that this end game is going to just
technically be a draw now so yan did
well to sort of immediately liquidate
everything after the move g5 if the
bishops estate on the board I think this
was a great idea for kramnik but in the
game it turns out black is just able to
get those bishops off immediately and
because of that I do think that g4 g5
was actually a bad decision so a little
bit of back and forth on that I like the
idea I really like the idea of g4 g5 to
hem in the king but the specifics just
don't work out for kramnik as after
Bishop d4 without dark screw bishops on
the board blacks position is now looking
very very fortress like in a very very
difficult to crack okay so what would
have been better for kramnik well in
this type of position sometimes the best
thing you can do is just make eight
billion moves until your opponent
blunders I also think that maybe it's
advantageous if these guys fall off the
board but not the dark squared bishop as
the LightSquared Bishop is doing a great
job of holding everything together
whereas the dark squared bishop are
allowing some more attacking
opportunities for white so what could
white have done instead well what white
can always do in these positions which
is just play 8,000 more moves and try
and wait for some kind of slip-up by
black you know just these types of
maneuvering moves in the game though we
do some fish 54 which is great by young
and now after a few more moves the RIC
stays active we see passing by black and
now black actually activates the King
but as I've said before doesn't actually
do too much just sort of shuffles
and it turns out there's just no good
way to make progress here more moves and
more chess moves and the rooks come off
the board
King e4 but there's simply no way to
make progress in this endgame Kramnik
tried efore here the key point is that
if f5
black does very very easily actually
have a draw in these positions it takes
takes and the move f6 and off the bet
you might not expect this to be a draw
but the idea is pretty similar to some
ideas that you see in opposite colored
bishop end games the point is that with
the King in front of the club sorry King
f8 this King gets to the g7 square from
g7 it defends f6
so it effectively nullifies both of
these ponds and now the only way to make
this King move is by zoogs one if you
can manage to sort of trap this bishop
then you can win this game but white
actually has no way of attacking a dark
square so there's no way to kick this
King off with g7 and so because there's
no way to fully trap this bishop on a
wide-open board this endgame is just
strictly drawn which is why Kramnik
meant 35 and now this is obviously going
to be a draw as well
black just keeps an eye on the f5 Square
and there's no way to advance well here
I actually gives up the f5 Square but it
still doesn't matter and the game was
agreed to a draw so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this edition of the endgame
lecture once again this was a special at
home Edition still in that home edition
I have exciting news I've tested
negative for kovat so I'm happy I'm
healthy I hope I can get back into the
studio for you guys to keep bringing you
these lectures get back with my producer
Ben Simon so I don't have to work so
hard on getting the intro to actually
work but for the moment I hope you guys
did enjoy the at home for
and hopefully it's not too much of a dip
in quality and that's gonna be it for
tonight on YouTube we are going to be
continuing the action on Twitch with a
special edition of analyze your games
where I analyze your games other than
that thank you so much for watching this
has been the endgame class and I will
see you next time
[Music]